Not every chilling horror scene makes it to
the big screen.
Whether for pacing reasons, keeping the MPAA
rating at an accessible "R," or simply the
filmmakers going in a different direction,
these scenes were left on the cutting room
floor — but they're no less terrifying on
their own.
Here are some of the scariest deleted scenes
from your favorite horror movies.
But beware...the spoilers!
The cocoon room
There were a lot of ideas that never came
to fruition in Ridley Scott's Alien, but what
we were left with was still a groundbreaking
extraterrestrial thriller — often imitated,
never quite matched.
The plot follows a commercial space crew awoken
from stasis after receiving a signal from
an alien craft.
They're overrun by the bloodthirsty extra-terrestrial
monster, with Officer Ripley emerging as the
central heroine and only survivor.
One of the deleted scenes from the film might've
answered a few questions left about the alien
— and escalated the fear factor.
In this cocoon room scene, Ripley happens
upon the trapped bodies of the deceased Brett
and the still-alive Dallas, whose whereabouts
were otherwise unknown after they ran into
the creature in the original cut.
As an act of mercy, Ripley has to fire-blast
Dallas, which is pretty raw, even for Alien.
The baboon cat
The Fly is a seminal piece of horror, with
or without its scariest deleted scene.
The sci-fi thriller followed Seth Brundle
as he became a victim of his own oddball scientific
experiments.
He slowly morphed into a human-fly hybrid
that was desperate to save his new species...by
making a baby with his human girlfriend.
In this deleted scene, even though Brundle's
teleportation experience has clearly altered
his own DNA, he's still splicing animals together
in his lab.
This time, it's a baboon and a house cat,
which when combined becomes a two-headed,
sharp-toothed beast that goes on the attack
and has to be exterminated.
It might've been a bit too obvious as foreshadowing
if left in, but the scene definitely doesn't
offer much hope for Brundle's own future as
a fellow lab mutant.
"I'm scared."
Uh, yeah.
Visions of Hell
Event Horizon is filled with stomach-churning
imagery.
The movie followed a space crew as they attempted
to make contact with a vessel that was temporarily
lost to a black hole, and layered itself with
disturbing visuals before jumping headlong
into a living nightmare.
But as sinister as the scenes of this space
inferno already are, the movie's original
vision of the bad place was even more disturbing.
"A dimension of pure chaos.
Pure evil."
In this deleted scene, Dr. William Weir has
been fully transformed into the slash-faced
demon that haunts the ship and its remaining
crew, and Captain Miller is chased down and
treated to an extreme vision of the other
side.
Impaled, limb-ripped bodies are on display
as the living are tied down and tortured.
The plights of these human souls may differ
slightly, but the suffering is universal.
Given the graphic nature of this footage,
it's not hard to see why an abbreviated version
was ultimately what made it into theaters.
Even Dante might've shuddered at the sight
of this much underworldly punishment.
Dr. Satan's last lunge
With The Devil's Rejects, writer-director
Rob Zombie took a decidedly different approach
to the macabre than he did with its predecessor,
House of 1000 Corpses.
Rather than relying on gruesome imagery in
the loathsome lair of the Firefly family,
the movie leaned harder on a slow burn of
emotional torture and depravity as it followed
the three lead escapees through one final
round of destruction.
For that reason, this deleted scene wasn't
a good fit.
In the clip, we meet Dr. Satan again.
The character's twisted experimental surgeries
featured prominently in the first film, and
in Rejects he's been captured by the authorities.
But he isn't as subdued as they think.
His unsuspecting nurse gets her throat ripped
out after he awakens from his feigned coma,
and the move is so quick that the police and
medical personnel can do nothing to stop her
from bleeding out on the hospital floor.
The tilted room
The adaptation of Stephen King's 1408 follows
skeptical haunted house story author as he
rents out a deadly hotel room that's claimed
the lives of dozens of occupants over the
last century.
What happens next is a bit formulaic, but
is bolstered by sensory immersion with enough
paranormal surprises and emotional scenes
to stick.
In this deleted scene, Jon Cusack's estranged
wife has been summoned to the hotel by his
supernatural doppelgänger, and he's powerless
to stop her from trying to enter the room.
As he tries to get close to prevent her from
joining him, the room tilts to a degree that
disables him from reaching the door.
For all the elemental frights the room provided,
this had to be the most disorienting, despite
being deleted.
The final cut
The theatrically released ending of Paranormal
Activity was pretty upsetting.
In the film, Katie and Micah are a young couple
who've moved to the wrong house at the wrong
time and can't shake the terrorizing spirits
that came with it.
Despite their best efforts to exorcise the
evil spirits from their home, Katie is eventually
possessed by the demon spirit, and appears
to end Micah by summoning him downstairs and
then hurling his bloody body at the camera
they'd been using to document their haunting.
She then shuffles onscreen, looks at the camera,
and offers a smile that makes it clear she's
given herself over to evil.
In the original ending, though, Katie returns
to the bedroom in what appears to be a trance
and sits rocking on the floor as time passes.
Eventually, the police show up, find Micah's
body, and make their way upstairs to Katie.
She snaps out of her trance, but police believe
she's a threat and shoot her.
The scariest version, though, is the alternate
ending, when instead of launching Micah's
body at the camera, she returns to the frame
herself, covered in blood and holding her
kitchen knife which she then uses on herself.
Chance are this one was passed over because
it would've ended the hit franchise before
it began, but still.
What a way to go.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!